[Music]
yeah we are live baby
welcome to the lions den the lions den
by money lion
get your intros man we're here with the
boys forget your intro we're at the
super bowl we're at the super bowl and
we're at mike type mike you got a nice
house man thanks for having me
this is a beautiful great house man i
got it on the market you're interested
in buying it
how much how much i take twelve bucks
[Laughter]
lenny kravitz had something to do with
it i think they designed it that's what
they said
i guess they want me doing the intro but
i feel like i mean come on right direct
to my left daniel cormier light
heavyweight champion heavyweight
champion analyst extraordinaire after
ufc brandon marshall all pro badass
podcast game
and now now i'm i'll give out your other
accolades with you know but really
you're definitely the heavyweight the
better heavier weight in the world oh
wow ufc we talking about unifying the
divisions if you want to go boxing and
there's a conversation between is boxing
on it down or is it ufc on the up it
doesn't matter i take on cormier i'll
take on mike tyson
right here
we'll see what's up at halftime
the man all the way at the end the
legend the one the only iron mike tyson
thank you yeah thanks for having us
brother appreciate you man
appreciate you so listen the big the
bangles are going to kill these guys
okay you think the banker's gonna get
that money on me oh wow you've got a lot
of money money on anything why are you
that why are you so sure mike i feel
dangerous
that feels dangerous
but mike this is this is where it it's a
conflict of interest because i'm a rams
fan but now i know you got all this
money on it i can't root again if you
put all this money on it hey it's the
whole is about the excitement of the
game yeah i feel you you're no ram fan
you're a broncos fan don't pull this
[ __ ] on us though don't do this i live
in los angeles [ __ ] that now i'm around
i've been there you thought but still
you didn't like this before they got
this good no you're right
what do you think you're doing listen
they come out the rams right now are
coming out conservative that's what
three running plays in a row
you know they're trying to ease into the
game
nerves you know this man nerves are high
how many times you had millions of
people watching you see this one right
here henderson come on he's a former new
orleans
guy so you respect greatness you expect
greatness
right you look at him in cincinnati
yeah getting the second little guy moved
up big guys but you was a little guy you
was a little guy moving big guys you
know that don't matter exactly that's
why
there you go
you got to think about leaving what mike
just said you know he talking about
little guy moving a big guy
yeah don't matter it's about your
technique it's about your feet work this
is what's there all right when they got
the statistics they say six five six was
crazy
they can't how do you measure the heart
and the will you can't do that
so all that's [ __ ] so tell us how do
you how do you do it if you see a
fighter you see a football player how do
you measure their heart their will how
do we do that you do that by their
dedication look at that dedication i
can't really hear
what they're willing to do in the other
plays tonight i can't hear mike at all
man
hey brandon let me ask you this
who would you rather have played for he
got stafford who's obviously bombs over
baghdad joe burrow or joe burrow joe bar
i'm running away i'm going run baby look
at the movie yeah because think about
like um
i love his swagger
you know and i also he can do it all i
mean he his football iq is through the
roof he can make every throw on the
field but i need a i need a quarterback
that's also
gonna
go out to dinner with me i need a
quarterback that's also going to come to
the crib and chill have you ever played
with a quarterback that did that for you
yeah jay cutler was one ryan ryan uh uh
uh fitzpatrick i love ryan's russell
wilson i had a couple of guys but but to
see the the the things with me i had 17
different quarterbacks 17 17.
you can't really build that relationship
wait two minutes you know
brenda let me ask a question
the rams just came off conservative
here's my i always wonder about this is
football they get that they get the
third long and they always run the ball
right why
it's like they don't try to get the
first down because statistics right like
you know when we go wednesday we sit
down and we put in our we start putting
our game plan thursday is when we do
third down okay so thursday we're only
working on third down and we're looking
at third and short what is third and
short first and first of three yards uh
third and medium six to seven third and
long ten eleven so we're putting in
three or four points you never wanna be
in third and long because statistically
speaking like you're only going to
convert those probably ten percent of
the time
right so
you don't wanna make a bad situation
worse you don't want to go out there and
throw and get an interception it makes
the game worse so what we do we do draws
we do screens yeah every single time
every single time
we're looking at the numbers yeah
conversion to be really good on third
down we need to be converting and these
are super bowl teams and both of them
are
fifty percent of the time we need to be
converting on third down yeah but that's
the problem is like because everybody
does the same thing they never get third
down very right because every time you
throw the screen they they're ready for
it yeah but you're looking at we know
that going in we know these screens and
these run plays it's all good we're just
trying not to make the situation worse
okay but if it's third and short oh yeah
we're getting after if it started medium
we're getting after third and long
most teams are saying
we'll live to see another another series
mangoes bango bang girl
now i'm stressed out now you gotta root
for the [ __ ] bag
baby we're gonna do it the underdogs
yeah can you put it up for me
can you hear it through your air yeah
you can hear them through a year no we
you know getting cold they got [ __ ]
at that mercy naked all the time get
cold for us we gotta go out in the cold
and get some life they're giving out
some cash too man my friends at
moneyline download the moneyline app
right now get your money war tag going
because that's my money
every quarter a hundred grand man with
money line make money watch super bowl
with this download
i can do it
i can make a bet every quarter
you're going to make a bet every quarter
mike is this possible yeah you go over
your bingos that go joe burrow right
here joe burrow
joe
lsu
lsu's
mike talk to me about mindset you know
why they're going to win the game
because the other team came out ran the
ball three times in a row
and they came out throwing
because they can't get democratic
because they're holding them to consider
we always fighting when y'all fighting
do y'all ease into the fights or are
y'all coming out
right out of there
so i had to kind of attack people right
right i was i was the team that didn't
have the the talent right i was the kid
i was the guy that needed to go and put
pressure on people
because if i stand back i was fighting
that light heavyweight in heaven right
dudes are tall but also
but also for dc
if you rush and you try to blitz these
seasons
so the thing was they would try to stay
on the outside so i would have to be the
advancing party because if not they're
kind of just picking me chipping me
three yards
but think about this situation though
right now you got the l.a rams they got
all the biggest stars in the world and
they came out playing conservative right
yep you got the cincinnati bengals and
they come out and did they get the first
down first down but they go around
passing to me that says a lot about
their mindset and they have that first
down yeah but now now they're getting
momentum so i'm gonna third down now
they're gonna put right i think you're a
little more lucy this time a little more
loosey-goosey and then also
what i love about the rams you gotta
decide are you gonna double cooper cup
who's the best chief in the nfl and then
leave old el beckham one-on-one you know
what i'm saying that's right that's a
good deal that's a great point you gotta
think about this you can't you can't and
this is where matthew stafford had to do
a phenomenal job of protecting the
football and making the right decision
oh they're going for it on fourth down
guys
that's what i'm talking about listen
though and they're throwing the ball oh
oh oh he forced him to chase ramsey
and he forced it in the chase
he never looked at anybody else
he didn't look at it
he looked at chase the entire time
they [ __ ] fat but they don't [ __ ] long
okay
yo he looked at chase the whole time the
whole time running back field that was
wide open yeah they're running back in
them
brandon that's why you said you'd rather
play for joe burr i know he's a great
quarterback if you play for the rams we
had cooper cup on the other side no
you're getting one-on-one coverage ding
ding ding well go back to 2018 brandon
why are you going to the giants why
because odell beckham james is over on
this yeah he's in the home receiver he's
gonna get double now i'm gonna be
backside one on
so it's exactly what you said what do
you do if you're a defensive coordinator
but the interesting thing about this
matchup
is that they're not playing a lot of
man-to-man they're gonna play zone so
they're not gonna go and match up and
yeah they gotta they gotta lean coverage
they gotta take out odell
cooper cup double him on third down
double odell on first down oh wow
because because that was the big play
cooper cops gonna beat each other no no
no they both big play both things
[Music]
is something we've never seen like the
49ers that last week like come on how
does that happen come on bro what the
[ __ ] were the db's doing from the niners
come on man how you could beat that bass
oh my goodness i don't smoke
take the tv
[Laughter]
you take uh
the the poison from frogs you still
messing with them frogs
the psychedelic frogs every day every
time i get a chance
why are you taking it it make you like
you know hey i got a buddy that he loves
it
he's just like it took him on a trip
that he's never like he will tell
everybody about it now really he is
literally the spokesperson for doing
that so so
you seem like a button but i was i'm
like i'm not doing it it's not in my
personality that's not because i don't
know
if i'm end up running around like butt
ass naked
crazy [ __ ]
and then espn gonna be called like hey
yeah
[Laughter]
they're like yo you're not even running
through l.a you're running through san
jose but has negative on the street look
at him right he locked in on chase the
whole time
take the flat you only need one
and you see ramsay them dudes all they
they they bracketed that was an iffy
call i don't know if you make that call
this early in the game
here's the thing i think it speaks to
the mentality of the teams right because
cincinnati's not supposed to be here now
they're not built right playing with
house money they're playing with houses
yeah let's go baby go fill that hole
they playing with house money yeah no
running
it's like
the rams are built to win today
they're built to win today we're stacked
but not
not the uh
the bengals aren't supposed to be no
because living in l.a the ram every rams
game is on yeah they take games off
they're so talented yeah they just take
games off
no stephanie
hurt that uh
that didn't look good just now
yeah
i don't like how they protect the
quarterbacks so much now the tom brady
rule this this whole they don't let
these dudes tackle the quarterbacks at
all
well they're pretending even when you're
falling like you could fall and like
fall into the guy's legs a little bit
that's a penalty
it's bad that's not good
third and fourth let's go rams all right
here we go so where are we at we got
third and four this is short this is
third and short you're talking about
what seventy percent of the time you're
gonna see one on one
okay like let's see do we have
one-on-one coverage so now you got
stafford looking at cooper cup as his
number one option come on cooper cupping
come on go get that
red hat
come on
listen think about this this is what
make this guy special he wasn't even the
number one option right here but he
caught the ball behind the sticks and he
made a guy miss we call that yak daddy's
yeah oh my goodness look at this but
look that's the difference right that's
the difference in stafford and burrow
burrow he wasn't the number one option
bro was long chase this dude went
through the moves got it over
that's right he didn't move though
yep that went through his progression
you're right burrow locked in on his
number one on his number one target
for that
let's not forget stafford went through
something okay let's go get him
receivers in detroit where you know
calvin johnson those guys one year
removed
big [ __ ]
so much
all right here we go with the situation
we're in the red zone right now it's
second to six this is a perfect time for
a run okay perfect time for a run or you
just throw a quick game quick game is
anything five yards or less
because you guys come on get them get
the phone get out go back there you go
pick up three four we're good
so the reason why this is good we call
this
we're we're
we're in we're in we're in routine we're
on pace we're just trying to get on the
board right now the only thing we're
trying to do on offense let's go back
it's trying to get to third and short
third and manageable that's it there you
go so now you're third and three you
need to be converting 33 at like 70
conversion
these are the things that we think about
and now we work through throughout the
week people think we just go out and
play football we go out there and play
football it's like we spend more time
studying
than we do actually practicing i don't
play football anymore right not in
practice all right here you go we got
empty formation three by two cooper cup
one on one what does that help doing
cooper jump about to get a touchdown oh
oh dude
oh oh no do it mike do it mike do it
[ __ ] that
beckham yes oh there what you think
about odell he's incredible why is he
incredible because listen he's the
consummate professional you know every
time you see him he's constantly
[Laughter]
catching the first touchdown that's big
my boy mike talking great job old dale
mike's so chill i can barely hear him
yeah yeah
you got to talk louder
what we smoking what you smoking what
you smoking oh where'd it come from i
got my zone
roll it up let's roll it out roll it up
you're gonna be the only one smoking it
he's the only one wrong he worked for
the mouse he worked for something
i don't smoke
yeah
i always see you posting that about
whistling
all kinds of different things here's the
question yeah are we still on right now
are we still rolling all right good
here's the question
do you roll your own blunts
or do somebody else you have a guy mike
he's a full-time job he is the guy that
makes hundreds a year rolling blocks
mike
you guys
mike he rolls your [ __ ] here
he has a full-time job what's his name
what's his or her name what's her name
troy troy
is he good at what he does you know
best ever
what makes a good uh blunt and roller uh
mike don't smoke blood to smoke joints
periodically free rolls
no um i have my own drink on my own
blunts
mike tyson man got a
roller no you have to look up tyson 2.0
what's tyson 2.0 it's the biggest weed
cook in the world
biggest weed company in the world check
it out man i got them in 18 states i
know you know i guess in 18 states
listen mike's the elon musk and weed
really yeah
yeah but the the coolest thing about
fighting is like
another oh yeah you do mushrooms
i'm on my shoes now
i'm high right now well educate the
people how do we see you know the
science behind it mike you know the
science you got you're educated why is
this stuff important to you
it's a connection it's a connection with
the divine leadership you have a
connection with god
mike doesn't it doesn't bring you down a
level two like you run at 10 when you're
on psychedelic it makes you more human
they could [ __ ] with you really he could
[ __ ] with you make you
it could it could build you up and stop
bringing some some rhyming
bring some grimy demons from the past
yeah
do you have a ghost up baby hey we're
sitting here
we go
my
three champions
that's good baby hopefully uh hopefully
none of those demons come out mike you
start attacking people not today
hey mike you ever get too high and like
like tigers and [ __ ] still or no say
what you ever get too high and make
crazy purchases
no
absolutely man i know what's that what's
the what's the craziest purchase you've
made over the last two years
cause you've been in your bag the last
two years i've been good i've been doing
that but like um
buy property
you're buying businesses now yeah that's
an investment though
[Applause]
listen think about how amazing that is
right the mike tyson to me when you talk
about i got my own roller but then you
go back to with mike tyson the big crib
and the lions and the tigers in the back
whatever
and now we made rolls-royce a legendary
story going through the through the toll
a dude didn't have a car and mike said
here take my keys it was a rolls-royce
is that true oh listen to this one
that's a true story no
no no it happened
i was um
i was married the first time i'm only 21
years old i'm married my wife i go into
a restaurant with my wife a fat food
drink hungry she goes in my pocket to
get the money she pulls out some condoms
she gets in my car the rolls royce and
she ramps it into some other car breaks
the guy's arm right
and so
all of a sudden she's screaming the cops
come up
i don't want the cops to lock up so the
guy saying my arm is broken right my arm
is broken
the first guy i gave some money stack of
my mother ten thousand take it right he
went into off track bet and started
betting and one guy came up
and said oh my arm is broken i told the
cops and huh you can have this man it's
all good i got too much [ __ ] you guys
work hard to risk your life take the car
and when the guy said
sir my arm is broken hey i'm telling you
one more [ __ ] time to [ __ ] up my face
said that because he heard that car once
he said once he did that i thought oh i
know i'm out of it i didn't want my wife
to get arrested she just broke [ __ ] the
guy up ran into the car who was the wife
at the time what's her name you know
[ __ ] robin gave me yeah
she's your mic
they drove my boy crazy right yeah
this is what i love about you and your
journey mike is that okay boom that's
where we were 20 30 years ago but now
you talk about disposable income and now
you buying properties and businesses and
you talking about your own
marijuana company right
so listen no listen
if you don't have nothing worth losing
all that [ __ ] you don't have nothing
right you have to have something that's
worth tearing yourself down right
all right here we go get back to
football third and fourth did i teach
you now
now
um
you know what you know what joe burl's a
little flustered he's a little off no
you didn't get started yet
all right fellas remember we're giving
away 25k a quarter that's a hundred
thousand dollars in the super bowl
download the money lion app right now
we're giving away 25 bangles bangles
come on bangla like money might give
everyone that comes from mike that's all
my personal bank account come on
he's not trying hard enough they had
they had what they wanted yep you got
one-on-one what did i say
you're going to get one-on-one coverage
mono imano 70 of the time yep they got
exactly what you they wanted
and he didn't hit it
the running back got caught up he got
tripped but he had it now we call that a
big box fade it was perfect let's feel
like in the same way especially
capitalized man you know yeah but like
feet and their feet hit each other
that's the stuff ah joe burrows off yes
but that was born that was just a
situation where the running back feet
got tangled with the
anyway i linebackers
mike might be about to give up
nah good night's out still how about
that [ __ ] yeah it's just started
just starting
that's right see he used to going what
is it three we only got five yeah 25
minutes that's the difference yeah it's
different these dudes go 36.
that 36 minutes is is a nightmare right
but the three minute round three minute
rounds but listen though i feel like the
three-minute round makes you want to
fight harder because it's shorter but
they they don't really get started six
rounds there
mike mike what was the mentality going
into round 10 11 12.
i don't gotta wear this guy now
trying to wear the other guy there when
he got late yeah avoid as many punches
as possible of course
punching to the body to the body hey
mike let me ask you this you know tyson
fury and francis delgado
pretty sure they're gonna fight a year
from now they're gonna fight yeah how's
that go down with francis and tyson fury
oh man no bro hey you know what's crazy
hold on i can't everything let me just
say this before mike answers let me just
say this mike you gotta give me a
company answer bro i listen no shut
listen
bro watching watching the fight
against uh cyril chirogun i'm watching
it and i'm thinking to myself love
francis
can't box will tyson furiously get a
blown out mclaren
no it's a difference right mike you
agree michael no absolutely listen
you had a blown out mcl 24-0
24-0 he had an mcl acl
right leg
three weeks before the fight still be he
out he you know he took his heart he
took cyril's heart a little bit because
listen right
man for man he can't beat cyril
he can't beat him in a straight up fight
free fight man for man he got to get him
he had to rough him up
you can't fight that guy he can't fight
that guy head up no he's there for
losing games mike but that's part of the
fight to take down yeah but you love the
takedown because when you're standing
you come up out of your feet you jump
and i know there's a point you know and
i know he can't fight this guy mike
jumped there with michael he can't fight
that guy head up like that i'm looking
directly at my my jump out of the seat
and went crazy up in there so so you
boys don't want to see francis with
tyson i just think that a box
francis of course i want to see it yeah
of course i want to watch it but i'm
just saying i don't know france will
make a lot of money that's what we want
yes france will make a ton of money i
just want no people don't know this
boxing [ __ ] is tricky why is it true
i go like that i said listen do this put
them in there with a a golden gloves or
a national champion the heavyweight
division no we need money just let them
smile we'll spar with them we need money
those guys those guys that throw those
big shots like francis because francis
can get a bit wide at times
if he lands knock you off those guys
though you kind of touch them up yes
that's true but
you gotta be careful with the other guys
coming too that's absolutely you gotta
anticipate his punching by punching and
moving after he punched i'm saying if
you fought a guy like francis that
throws wide like that you inside all
that right inside
watching inside the punch but but then
also let's not get twisted
in some weird world and francis
lancaster is almost on tyson it's all uh
i'm ty's inferior it's over really it's
too hot
you know how many professional guys that
punch
hard tried to hit him and can't do it i
know yo that's what i was going to say
that's what you say right fury
[Music]
francis because he fought deontay he's
kind of seen a version of you having the
wrong conversation right now why because
the conversation and the question right
now is mike tyson in his prime versus
fury in his prime who wins mike
that's the question
mike before you answer this is no
disrespect to me he big
technically wise fury can go he can go
defense his footwork's big to me as far
as technique wise fear is the best we've
ever had oh wow what you doing tyson
hits the hardest treatment mike
he might try to lean on you might try to
grab you lean on you i don't know he's
rude right now michael's like i'm
fury in his prime enticing this crime
who wins telling people the truth
listen
just him being tightly fairy shows my
greatness
tells you my great yeah it shows his
hey that's good named him after him
yeah mike that's a great answer i don't
want to know i don't care if he could
beat me or not
he named that his name is tyson his name
is tyson and his dad i don't care he
could beat me he could beat me i don't
care the name of tyson named after the
greatest fighter ever lived greatest
that was the that was the greatest
that's the one right i love mike tyson
he's one of my best friends in the world
who's this
a drake look-alike come here got a white
jacket
he didn't like drake didn't he
all right here we go
come on
[Laughter]
so listen here's the situation we're
still in the first quarter b
two minutes left we're in sunny
man
the heat index is out of this world
right now it's never been this hot in
l.a this time of year for hydration yeah
i'm hiking dehydration play a role a
factor in this game
what was that mike what you got
some fruit might got a fruit plate
[ __ ] want to eat [ __ ] yeah
hey
yes we want to eat
come on get some of this everybody you
know what i ain't looking like
you know what i'm going for
blueberries he went for blueberries
might help him
mike mikey
thank you
what the [ __ ] are we doing in there
you're eating blueberries and chilling
man you want some some grapefruit i'm
standing better get some grapes
let's go let's go two rounds real quick
oh yeah
mike you like rose fargo i love him he's
the man huh yeah
you got some good cardio mike yeah
are you ready for us man
dc you know i got it we got to bring it
up last night's ufc that you worked
robert whitaker izzy
decision yeah robbie whitaker he's gonna
have a tough fight again yeah you had a
tough fight i i watched it this morning
i had you guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
breakdown on you might have had you beat
here mike on this shot mike it looked
like you got a body shot over the left
he had a right hand about to drop him
again check this out look look mike it
looks like you might have had your beat
buddy come on again i'll give him i'll
give him another opportunity i'll give
him another opportunity don't mike it
look like he had you i ain't [ __ ]
i ain't this boy crazy man come on hey
mike you have to put him down mike
stop
all right
you poking the beer right now man boys
[Laughter]
oh here you go mike tyson getting makeup
of course he got his own professional
roller
he has lions and tigers
[Applause]
check it out that's one on one was it
first down because we were boxing
go around second down
marsh
talk about greatness this is greatness
oh my god fix your mic
fix your mic marshall they say that when
you go they say with ramsey
they say when ramsay flew outside and
shut down this side oh it's going down
right now
going down right now oh
[Applause]
mike talk about greatness we're in the
super bowl was first down
he catches the bomb on jalen ramsay the
best quarterback
in the nfl the last three years not just
this year closest thing we have
greatness it's gonna be a war
not gonna be easy game that's what we
want i want a high scoring back and
forth we don't want this [ __ ] to be
boring
look at that so they gotta finish listen
you can't where did that go what is that
calling the ball
batted pass it's not crazy that they got
von miller
and aaron donald next to each other on
that side the russia got a free hit oh
my goodness me that boy
that was [ __ ]
yeah let's do that well hit him low but
listen look how hard it is now we're
third and ten again what do you do if
you're in this situation run the ball
you're in the red zone
you keep the field goal or do you know
you got to take your points you got to
take points after what you told me after
what you told me 10 completion so here's
something
so they're going to play the front of
the end zone look at the safeties
they're at the front of the engine you
have the back pedal
whoa
i'm saying it's hard look look it's hard
ramsey it's hard to get down there but
they couldn't score now you got to kick
three
it's good this is a win for the
cincinnati bengals but it's hard once
you get into tight red when you're
inside this point when you're inside of
the 15 we call this the titan rings
man i you can't go you'll go for
touchdowns
but early you've got to get your man put
up points earlier you gotta take their
points that's what we do
like i'm part of the team
so jayla ramsey gives up a big play then
he comes down and he stops them fully
redeeming himself got it listen next
next next next play
y'all got time to look well we got three
you got three right there should come
over how did i know that carpet little
girl's got it that's like a carpet
or did you take this
[Music]
[Laughter]
here's the thing when i played against
darrell reeves i played against bailey
the best of the best
you have literally a half a second
to actually beat them well i used to
tell my quarterbacks if i ran out slant
that same slant against darrell reeves
if you don't throw it before i even come
out my break it's all the balls going
the other way jayla ramsey almost picked
that ball off when you're going against
elite cornerbacks
man the timing is everything
tell me i don't get inside leverage on
this boy man y'all mind you don't get
inside leveraging this morning
i don't get it i'm not wide receiver but
tell me
this guy man look look at that look at
that food
hey
i didn't know it was you i was looking
at you i'm [ __ ] up
look i said man put it right there man
oh my god
the inside huh oh my god he jumping
on the inside he couldn't even move then
he said that's the best one i said you
might want me to get a [ __ ] i might call
for a fade wrong right right marshall
anybody want ginger ale
man thank you mike you're not getting
out of here
is that your company event last time you
own a ginger rail company
i rewatched this morning i did a fight
command last night i was drinking yeah i
got it
yeah
i have a dream company won that fight i
think four to one money man are you
three to two tyson 2.0 tyson 2.0
second round i thought that robert
whittaker could have won the round
because he had his back third round i
thought easy one hundred percent fourth
round easy one
whitaker won round five that was his
best round yep so i thought it was three
to two that's fair but the problem is
the judges some judges gave rob round
three
that's the problem that's because they
don't put any value in the like kids
they got some bad jokes
they
like you told me this morning like man
did you see that fight as close to
everybody else i was like when i watch
it like i don't see the
issue at all well when i walked when i
walked in there to interview
i figured izzy had one i just didn't
know how much he had one box
i didn't know if it was me three to two
or four to one but i thought izzy won
the fight yeah i was like there was no
like
so when the crowd reacts in the way that
they did they're booing
i was surprised i was like wow i was
like maybe i was watching a different
fight right now
but
48 47 48 47 49 46 all for
israel
[Laughter]
whitaker goes because he just grabbed
his [ __ ] hand bro
paper i swear to god it was the sickest
i love you israel is out there having
way too much fun he's a superstar
he's just grabbing his brother he
grabbed his hand bro like you beat him
up paper rock paper scissors no he's
like beat you already like it's over i
already got you bro he's having too much
fun
in the most long
is he caught two doves last night look
he's being raped
uh i mean come on man
[Music]
i mean
but
on first look you're like man i'll fight
who's beating is that 185 nobody has
been
nobody has been all right so it's the
best we have to offer
since we're talking about uh fighting
mike come back
come back
so we're talking about
fighting at the super bowl there's 150
million people tuning in to this super
bowl
i got a question for mike
mike
is this jake paul fight going down yes
or no
oh wow
it was logan paul i think right is it
logan or jake
let me check the next um
i didn't see the last check that they
offered me
what was the last check they offered you
it wasn't enough it wasn't enough not
enough to get mike out there what is
enough mike what's the number like
what's the number if i want to really
if i want to fight you what i got to
come up with
well you don't have to come up with much
you know
i think 25 million with you
[Laughter]
hey mike listen though but there's no
threat what you said is there a threat
is there a threat in that fight with
jake paul
and me yeah there's no threat i don't
think so and i mean realistically i
don't think so
yeah i i don't know man i think those
kids those kids can fight a little
better than people want to give him
credit for him well you know logan's a
businessman he's just trying to make
money
you can actually
[Music]
this is important get him get him
oh wow you said i gotta grab his ankle
real quick all right so all right here
we go we're third and long it's third
eleven
you
hey
oh my goodness brandon look at his hair
why are you waiting fighting forget him
i don't care about that
he looks like a character
don't stand with him
come on let's go come on let's go no no
let's go
[Music]
[Laughter]
stop
he's fighting for the championship
in the early spring yeah
and i like seven o'clock where are you
from
hey go get him he is legit hey brandon
he is legit the most scary contender
in the ufc right now that's your next
light
i've called it for two years now 100 100
he's your next
[Music]
here we go you want to sit down here
yeah please hey hear it
this guy's got some confidence in you
here we go guys we're in the red zone
this is the nice talking the mic if
you're talking about it get out
the rams starting to pull away
what are you doing out here
heavy on top i just want to be ready
yeah
bro you're in shape dog how much you
weigh right now how much you weigh right
now
2 15 15. oh he's not even cutting no but
i want to be i want to be ready all the
time
[Laughter]
hey mike please meet this guy man big
pleasure to meet you
thank you brother
short shorts
easy crazy bro what he did what he did
to anthony smith disgrace nuts he's the
real deal he's one of my favorites and
my favorite bro
who do you love fighting for the title
he's going to fight glover attacking
heavy weight you everybody everywhere
right here
hey glove is something like that right
he's been around for a while why don't
you go heavyweights like he's a champion
he jumps jumping and he idolizes you
glover moves like you do
he's a really good grappler black belt
but yeah yuri
can't believe
touchdown
hey i'll tell you who else just i'll
tell you who else just scored our boy
tyler just won 25 000
dollars from bunny life i'm telling you
now we're not messing around
tyler
from freaking i don't know where he's
from but that boy just won 25 25
000 money lines tyler let me hold
something buddy this ain't a game 20
minutes
money lying it's throwing out the bread
what'd they say how much money is gonna
be giving away a hundred thousand
dollars
25 000 every quarter
you gotta download the moneyline app
right now i'm telling you we just gave
away twenty five thousand dollars
you can wait download the app right now
moneyline app get your money more tag
going thoughts on social
they that wasn't a fake that must have
got blocked because why would you ever
try a fake if you got a line up so far
back now
100 you don't do that you can't feel it
it had to get blocked something happened
between the all right the center
so essentially when they move the extra
point back they've
eliminated the
the the fake the face right that is
total [ __ ] what's up brother you're
preparing for some for some fight or it
will be or not i've been having a good
time everybody everybody asked me for
that
are we still live right now
[Music]
hey listen
they're telling me you're the best one
the best i will be
no i'm not not yet because i'm coming
for that belt yeah i'm
that that's just being with him
i feel like i feel like b i feel like
he's too respectable right now he's too
humble gary yeah hey when you get out of
here look up yuri and ryzen and the [ __ ]
that's the characteristics of a real
assassin quiet night oh yes brother god
is great
brandon
bro
wild boy wild boy yeah but i feel like
he should be calling i feel like you
should be calling mike out right now
indeed
d.c
i'm done
you know this is what hey hey you know
hey you know that steak that when you
like get too drunk you forget it's on
the grill
[ __ ] turn black that's me
i'm done i'm overcooked and done you
done i'm done officially retired man i
retired two years ago almost never
coming back i'm coming back
you're done
i want to do this with you
all right bubba watson hey yuri
yeah we love you brother we're rooting
for you
get out of here
we got
we got bubba wallace nascar legend
and bush coming up right now i'm telling
you i guess oh super ball guess i'm
guessing
ma'am bubba wallace
yeah there's bubba wallace the legend
kurt busch legend what's up fellas how
you guys doing good luck john
brother get it done rooting for you man
yeah
enjoy go get em bro
don't forgive me when i'm in ringside
that boy can look more european
yeah bro we got we have the nascar
legends up there right now
[Music]
legends
hey i don't think they can hear us they
can't hear we got you now
what's up fellas how you guys doing man
what up what up we're doing good
how's your super bowl sunday going
uh i didn't have any skin in the game so
i'd say mine's doing okay
i got i got a one-man party over here my
wife's getting ready we're going to
valentine's day dinner because we got
daytona rolling up oh that's right
that's a pretty big event that's a
legitimate issue
that's ours
oh yeah yeah he's a bad snap bad snap
here you go hey hey bubba it's not a
basketball hey bubba kurt who's winning
this game we got any uh we got any
favorites
here la's looking strong right now
uh i i was kind of pulling for
cincinnati but
la's la's hot right now no bubba don't
do it i'm taking the mangoes man burrow
your style bubble jim mcmahon thing
going on and i love jim mcmahon and the
chicago bears and the 80s
all right make the pick who's going to
win this game
how you feel cincinnati how you fellas
feeling for the daytona man everything
going well how do you guys prepare for
it
yeah we're feeling good ready to roar
moneyline's all about being alive
and we're ready to roar daytona and so
uh it's coming up here and it's uh it's
gonna be a lot of fun brand new cars
coming over teamed up on the toyota side
so it could be a lot of fun really cool
i got my i got my new backdrop
oh i love it kurt there you go dog
curt
can you hear me
kurt can you hear me
mars we can barely hear you dog
all right y'all can barely hear me kurt
i got i got i got a confession
rowdy is my driver
and bubba those are my drivers
i think we all how do you feel about
that i think i think we oh there they
are yeah there's bubba he knows what's
up hey listen fellas don't come by
marshall because the moment you come
next to me try to fight russell you've
got to fight every person that has come
over here
hey kurt you're making a new move you're
going to a new team talk to us about
that new move brother
i'm digging it uh toyota asked me to
come in as a veteran and build a new
team up and build it alongside puppies
so
denny hamlin all these guys uh this is
the perfect scenario for me as a as an
old-school guy as a veteran and it still
has that drive to win oh you saw that
man can
and just partnering up with a new group
of guys it's uh this is what it's all
about cool sponsors as well with monster
energy mcdonald's money lying and uh i
think it's going down baby
i love it i love it it's b shop we got
dc
we got bubba wallace we got kurt bush we
got iron mike tyson here streaming live
this is legendary stuff
unbelievable money lion thank you so
much putting this together this amazing
event talk to me bubba wallace
sure hey
history history
bro
you want talladega talk to us about that
moment
good night
pushing for the witness
continuing to grow
and make big things happened was
so fun to be covered my last part my
career
we're just talking about
most of it had some fun and bringing
them
to the sixth grade british here
awesome looking lake wireless
get your internet right bubba you can't
like you can like take the sponsor's
money but not use them let me ask you
all questions cause we got some legends
on the down stream right now two legends
nascar you guys all right plate racing
somebody tyson mike tyson what's plate
racing
leave the [ __ ] out of me
bubba bubba tell her what plate racing
is
vomit tell him
[Music]
all right all right great great another
question it's like boxing with us
right right another question mike tyson
true or false
kyle
okay
rowdy
and kurt
are they related or not
the bush family i ain't saying nothing
about no bushman i just said kyle and
kurt
rowdy what's your nickname uh kurt
i i don't know i've been a bunch of
different names
the boss we gonna call you the boss yes
they're all family members they are yes
ding ding ding yes yes yes great job
great job they're freaking legendary and
they're from vegas
their father is phenomenal their father
helped him
yep
vegas in the house
bubba we love you guys
good luck tomorrow man
for you
stay safe man and keep crushing both you
guys thanks for coming on fellas
appreciate that thank you
later you got it guys hey anybody that's
tuned in there's money up for grabs from
daytona so you got to register the money
line raisins
there you go
they're giving money away during nascar
money money line all over the we're in
the red zone again guys
we uh uh iron mike has a a lot of money
on the line for the the cincinnati
bengals he's been a good driver okay six
second and six now it's third and short
if i'm mike tyson we want a touchdown
here mike
we're in two down territory already yes
let me tell you why
if i'm in this situation right now
second quarter seven minutes to go
i run the ball on third down and then i
see what position i'm in and i'm and
i'll give myself a run pass option we
call those rpos on fourth down hey hey
friend let me ask you this why is aaron
donald so good what's the deal aaron dar
step first off his mindset mike will
enjoy this this dude
is next level when it comes to mindset
he's a monster out there he's trying to
oh here we go here we go first down go
go another one
aaron donald is next level when it comes
to mindset 80 percent of the game 80
percent of sport is in your mind it's
mental
20 is physical so the physical he's next
level we're talking about a dude plays
deep into the line but he moves and runs
and he's built like a linebacker he's
jacked he's jacked
he's jacked but it all starts with his
mindset i saw aaron donald curse out a
guy on the field his own teammate i'm
playing against aaron donald when i'm
playing for the saints and our offensive
line is crushing
i'm playing for the seattle seahawks
they're crushing the la rims what are
they doing
and and aaron daughter looks as his
defensive lineman next to him and says
if you play like this if you let them
treat you like this your ass cannot be
on this field with me oh wow that's what
he said to his own team
his mindset is next level
marshall how was it playing for the
saints howard's playing the song
how is it living in like playing in this
like a city like that that's not one of
my los angeles one of my greatest
football experiences ever really oh my
god
oh
let's get this money money let's get
this money mike shadowbox shadowbox
let's get this money mike he said it
i did it mike wins this mike has a
thousand psychedelic trucks
there's a lot of money there's no
mushrooms around here the saints was
next level man one of my greatest
mushrooms in my car because it's not a
massive city
no but you have to do that ridiculous
they know how to party hey they kind of
suck now though
no they'll be yeah we could we killed
fighting but
dennis allen you know he was a defensive
coordinator so he's been around
hopefully dennis allen is next level
yeah he's a great coach so hopefully
who's the starter now for you guys well
last year
baby uh it was james what's good this
morning and they were all day every day
every night
a lot of money
if the cincinnati bengals wins oh my god
what is mike taking home
quarterback i've ever seen
oh man you know what i'm talking about
he was trash wasn't he oh my goodness we
went three and i fought than any team in
nfl he had one good game in the first
game in the ball without two
conversations travis
travis there you go trevor simeon
trevor simeon oh my goodness
trevor sent me he has everything
physically but that's necessary
it's not always the guys with the the
that's most gifted physically listen the
mentor is everything at that level
i was taught this about the mentor and
bodybuilding especially after you walk
away from the game it's everything you
know it i was taught this your body's
only purpose to carry your brain
look at that mike's smart man mike
goddammit mike tarzan
you're a philosopher like who do you
study what are you like where are you
getting this stuff from bro no you spent
games
on every show every podcast that you're
on
every time there's a camera in front of
you a mic in front of you you spit game
who are you studying bro i'm not saying
nobody everything i do
there's somebody's quotes but it's from
my experience in life i don't see nobody
quoting really some guys listen there's
some guys that never
control a baton of men an army and their
quotes are more legendary than god that
actually fought on the field yeah he's
like a bruce lee guy bruce lee never
gotten any [ __ ] he never fought anybody
but he inspired so many fighters yeah he
did can you believe that yeah and so
that
that's good too because that's in that's
um that's contributing to fighting yeah
so you got just as good as fighting yeah
yeah i just watch i just watch his uh
his movies
oh like the last dragon
yeah he was the man to me to me the
greatest athlete no
is bruce lee
listen listen it's my time that's my
time like this that's my time oh no
that's my [ __ ] guy
i thank you who do you have you can't
see that bruce lee
michael jordan
you should like that hold up
please please tell me why
statistically who's the best athlete of
all time
uh wayne gretzky
the most dominant figure [ __ ] words
that
dude look at the stats he's the most
dominant professional
ridiculous [ __ ] huh yeah you that's why
he's that bruce lee
serena
[Laughter]
150th ranked dude would beat the [ __ ]
out of sharing or venus destroy it yeah
destroy it no not 150. no you can't
though no those are facts
that's not true
what is wrong with y'all
yeah he might be no
you believe this [ __ ]
[Music]
the greatest athlete be careful now the
dude that like wins the olympics in the
uh decathlon that bruce jenner used to
win yeah
that's the dude ally
caitlin
when he was bruce jenner's talk to
colleagues
how many people compete in that they do
ten events brandon if he decided to do
it would win that event no bro you tell
me he's not better off leaving caitlyn
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
nobody who knows doesn't matter but that
person person's still the best outlet in
the world
that person is doing all right here we
go here we go you are breaking my heart
because that person could go play
football 10 people
that person from the olympics run around
[Music]
he was injured before he dropped the
ball yeah
[Music]
the commercials used to be a big deal
are they still a thing now is that a big
deal anymore i don't know i know pete
davidson is doing a lot of stuff for it
there's supposed to be some fire
commercials but
[Music]
bro why did you tell me i had that all
my shirt before you pulled this [ __ ] man
all right fellas remember moneyline is
giving out 25k a quarter that's a
hundred grand over the course of super
bowl all you gotta do is download the
moneyline app right now get your money
raw tag going follow us on social and
comment with your money war tag right
now 25k we've already given out 25k the
next winner is coming up stay tuned make
money watch the stream with us it's that
easy money line download the app right
now
damn bro you boys broke my heart with
that best athlete combo i don't want to
really i don't want to rehash it
you said some crazy [ __ ] man well you
said the craziest [ __ ] bruce lee the
best [ __ ] yeah i might believe that i'm
in fights [ __ ] this
you might be the best mind well see
that's the everybody's definition of the
athlete is different so you got to show
so then jordan peterson's a great app so
what is this you got to show up
how many of this is your deal
i can't you're
[Laughter]
she's the best female athlete of all
time no that's the problem is a female
she's the best if
serena williams the best athlete if you
put her mindset in anybody you have
michael jordan
she's the greatest so we can't it's hard
we're going for gender if we're going by
athlete based on mindset it's michael
jordan
serena williams
watch you pull up
oh damn yeah he blew that knee up
his hair looks dope though that's not
good
don't look good at all
[Applause]
out of all the times to do it out of all
the freaking times to do it
acl ncl
39 no they're going to super cup first
don't go for it cooper county buy one
eastern
[Applause]
they're not gonna do anything
mike what was your bet mike
straight up you got the bingos right
straight up
i like that bit
you like how the game is going right now
for your bingo i didn't like that pat
that pass just you ain't like that third
and now you ain't possible
like that conversion
that was too easy
mike we talking 50 g's on this game what
are we talking about
i was gonna bet something in that
quality but they understand about five
oh okay
mike tyson back five five they don't
wanna you pay your guy to roll blunts
that today dog
hey mark
uh whiskey yeah
i should have brought my whiskey man
all you boys are gonna text during the
stream all right
after talking all that trash about best
athletes now you jump on your phone
because he embarrassed you boys are wild
he's embarrassed
both people
i'm not wrong
i really believe
[Music]
get out come on stafford
yeah
that's a veteran move that's a veteran
move
mike say hi to v hey v how you doing
buddy
i'm doing well
[Applause]
[Laughter]
seven
thirty
hey and b marshall do you know did that
hedrick hedrickson the the captain for
bengals was he on ohio state when the
boso was on
are they the same class i think so but
but i really don't know i played with
him my last year oh he's a snug
he just stopped yeah he was the real
deal
he didn't even dress up in 2018 he was
on the bench
damn that's right that shows you what
kind of monsters in the nfl bro he was
sitting on the sideline
he wasn't addressing him sitting there
right next to him
i just i just had lunch with coach i was
like
[Music]
here we go third and fourteen starting
for 10.
[Music]
continues to get richer that's exactly
what you're saying
yeah
the rich continues my boy staffordshire
what does mike know about football
what does he know that i don't know team
gritty
team gritty how does he pick the
cincinnati's feeling good he's rolling
another blunt
look lol
[Music]
to come
mike you think you have 50 of them
mike you live in la vegas newport
i lived in vegas i moved out here for my
daughter to play tennis in newport beach
now we're moving to boca raton for my
daughter to play tennis let's go that's
where i live yeah that's where we going
florida i'm a trainer huh come to my
facility
yeah for my daughter she wants to be a
tennis player wins
that's when i want to be a golfer that's
where coco lives and yeah so mike what
about your podcast studio and all that
[ __ ] you guys gotta go down there now
you all gotta move huh yeah oh they're
all going are you coming down
um the end of
this month and next month
my job is to save money on that we got
aaron mike coming to south florida baby
let's go i bet the santa's here
i live 20 minutes away yeah
yeah
[Music]
yeah and physical therapy athletic
training all of that
recuperating that's right recovery
anti-aging
all of that
research
yeah we do all that of course
you got to
what are you doing man come here rocco
it's rocco mike he looks just like you
man
that's my boy
and he wants to be a golfer he is a
golfer
what
what's up
not great what someone told me to tell
you is ducky cash not drake
i don't know lucky has
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i don't know son we got we got
we got tiger woods 2.0 right here say hi
say hi to the people come here
come here tell us about your game we got
the microphone where's the microphones
come over here right here in between me
and dc because we don't want your dad to
jump in this conversation right now come
here
give him again boom boom
all right hello so we got young gym
right here young and tell us about your
game what's up brother um it's going
pretty good i'll start my tournament in
march 12th you think you can beat me
yeah
oh you see you got your name
oh
[Music]
you know what time it
is man y'all gotta throw a little cup
[ __ ] we even quite name it
everybody gotta see me come on
champions
first time
punch that [ __ ] punch him too big hand
him cheers
[Laughter]
biggest dude
no
hey he's about to get here
you're probably about to get this boy
here we go
this is the best wire receiver in the
game three years from now give us your
prediction
who's going to win the game talk to us
man
what's up look at this [ __ ] look what's
happening man this is already my scope
you're already like yeah
baby you talking into the mic
we locked the episode
you got [ __ ] i've been talking young
[ __ ] [ __ ] when we gonna see the jets in
the super bowl
man y'all just two in the episode man we
loading so that's right this dude right
here is next level i'm already mic'd up
gold feet he ready he's going to lead
the lead to the jets to the super bowl
manifestation we're putting in the work
he grind hard you keep going first he's
fighting again i'm not really too much
in the prediction it's about what we're
about to do
enough said now we go back to the
broadcast we got jennifer lopez emmitt
smith
watching live
and this is my team right here jets baby
jets
all right here we go guys hey what we
got to understand is this is elijah
moore
elijah moore tell these people
what round you went last year
you sitting there in new york with with
zach wilson and tell these people what
y'all learned
i mean i went i went second round
really went first in my head you know
really went number one really went top
ten
man we just about to be legendary he's
got two in there
so so elijah
we're sitting here watching the super
bowl you're idle now i wouldn't say your
idol guy that you study and look up to
odell you train odell beckham jr go feed
global down here in south florida how
did it feel seeing odell go down in the
biggest moment of his playing career
yeah we always gonna prevail though you
know we pray pray we prayers up so we
good everything's great man yeah we was
on the way here so we didn't see exactly
i'm getting text messages
we'll get a little update but you know
we're gonna let god handle the rest
that's awesome we got goldy global make
sure you go get the merch and support we
got elijah moore next level thank you
how you feeling all right
[Music]
man bless us for all of us man enjoy
today enjoy your families enjoy the ones
around you tonight
you know what i mean uh we don't have
tomorrow
so for everybody man just stay blessed
and let's go rams let's go bengals
you know what i mean
the way you win money you download the
moneyline app
and you can win twenty five thousand
dollars a hundred thousand dollars okay
our boy lakey coney i think that's a
real nickname lakey coney just won 25
grand
watching super bowl watching this stream
money line
lakey enjoy the money man
that i would take
[Music]
and don't wait too because the way you
win the 25k we're giving away 25k in the
third quarter fourth quarter it's a
hundred thousand dollars total
download the moneyline app right now get
your money raw tag going follow us on
social and comment with your money more
tag
download the moneyline app 25k got
nothing to lose facility bro
he lived right there in the plantation
this little [ __ ]
they like they let him walk around like
this
yeah yeah yeah nobody robbed you here
hey so you know he played for the jets
mike
picture picture picture
we got a camera
all right we got bob molly right camera
picture
photo
smoke man you want to take it for him
around
here we go
we got second to ten this is a big down
get him get him
here we go super cub they've actually
done a pretty good job
bro we'll make super cute touchdowns
this is the receiver we're talking about
a receiver watching
yeah wide receiver yes but i'm old i'm
retired he's active he's the next one up
what makes cooper cup special man
probably really just his man's patience
he look like he's real real pacing he
understands the zones he understands the
pictures
maze is a smart smart play you see the
way he talks he wait interviews man he
just knows what he's doing he knows
football
i love it last question for you before
we let you enjoy your your super bowl
watch party here with m with money lion
uh how much does your chain cost because
we're his money line is presenting
sponsor all right and we're talking
about money and financial literacy how
much is this this charm man a little
piece man
[Laughter]
love
respect
me thank you
[Applause]
it's almost half time
oh [ __ ] going down it's almost going
down and for the viewers out there on
half time we're going to take a little
break you guys enjoy the halftime show
and remember download the moneyline app
in the third quarter fourth quarter
giving away 25k all you gotta do is
download the app moneyline app get your
money roar tag going follow us on social
and comment with your money roar tag 25k
third quarter fourth quarter we've got
two guys win in the first and the second
quarter it's too easy man to make money
[Music]
that's it man we're about to go to
halftime enjoy the halftime show we're
going to get a break we're going to fuel
up on food and shrooms and
chronic and some chronic with mike enjoy
the halftime show we will be back for
the third quarter download the moneyline
app make some money we'll see you in the
third quarter
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
foreign
oh
what's up everybody thank you guys for
tuning in here we are at the money line
man the lion's den with mike money line
baby brandon marshall daniel cormier
money lion
why does cincinnati have 16.
they just scored because i know one two
three four five six oh 20 now 21 is it
21 no 17 i'm sorry
i'm [ __ ] up in math that's the problem
yo what up what up what up what up here
we go
and look who wins look who wins yeah but
push off uh
and the question was why is this number
still even available it's not out there
before the season outside
the vote
i don't want to talk to nobody
for the season
of super bowl will never see a reason
never retire but this is a great way to
go out and i love that refresh
i need a bottle of whatever brand of
marshmallows are in your leisure
financial freedom financial health total
you need to continue to teach us retired
guys and these active guys what to do
with that
it's vital tell me how to think you just
gotta hold them right here they gotta
hold them probably five hundred thousand
after these guys are moving mike i want
a high scoring game though i just want
to entertain people
on
bowl tv yeah
i want to straight up talk about like
for you coming into the league how is it
making mistakes financially like how did
you learn somebody taught you what you
had to learn on your own
there you go
yeah so what i did was yes
like basically like the financial
dictionary
and i got these uh these note cards and
on these note cards i wrote down all the
terms
you know what i mean i wrote down even
if it's a spring all these things
and i signed a 50 million dollar deal
but before i would invest my money
i would on every away trip and we're on
a plane to go into the new to the new
england patriots or the jets i would
actually take out all these notes note
cards it's about 50 note cards
so i would study i would study these
note cards before i would invest i had
50 million sitting in the bank before i
would even invest i wanted to understand
50 million in the bank basically that's
crazy
a lot 50 million dollar deal and i
didn't start investing until i
understood what all these terms meant
what is liquidity what is like something
simple is that well i want to know the
fundamentals before i sit at the table
with these people to say i'm about to
invest your money and now let's go joe
shy
22 interest are returned every single
year so my money's making money
nah that's that's so important that's so
important man so many people go broke
because they don't understand what you
just said 100 i mean you know we think
about uh money line that's why it's
important like where is the right
platform for us to go and partner with
to actually help entrepreneurs and
startups or just people who have what
they have to extend it you know i know
from my life expectancy standpoint that
my money is going to last my children's
children if i stick to the game plan
that we implemented 10 years ago
quickest guarantees
that's key i love what you're doing i am
athlete like you really are transcending
the game and becoming a media open too
yeah i mean that's the opportunity bro
like
one time raises all ships you know to me
i am at this incubator and accelerating
for talent around athletes
that's point blank period bro you know
it would be selfish of me now if i only
focus on myself and my platform can we
bring this right here that's the
question
they're in the franchises
nobody's really done that before in the
podcast space that's right i am at the
la i am at the houston bunbee kendrick
perkins la you got swaggy p
keenan beasley and it's the same thing
it's
talking about him first conversation we
have first time
[Music]
don't wrap them anymore though because
they never played joe burrow joe burrow
got that swagger up
ain't no stopping oh
ain't nothing ain't nothin
oh
skirmish breath we're just gonna let
[Music]
mike watch cincinnati
watch cincinnati i see aaron down trying
to put somebody in there
i like two games and the colors too like
the colors black and orange
and that's why
[Music]
we got playing football what would you
do
full back i would want to be whatever
lawrence taylor was
live london
yeah
yeah no no no i wanted to be lt if i
would if i would play football i
wouldn't want to be him yeah
[Music]
there was a husband and wife that was
split up husband was sitting in
first-class white position and i don't
know
what you guys
coach
going for three lt
his wife just said you know what take my
seat because i said go to your husband
take my seat i'll go sit in coach
legendary he's going for he's going for
he's going for it first class humility
bro great athlete too
he's going for it a great athlete could
perform when he's hurt
so so we gotta earn your leisure here
what's up brother ladies and gentlemen
so so these dudes yeah they talk about
that's getting money right now what
should they do with it how should they
be thinking how should they be
approaching it because we gotta earn
your leisure here well first the thing
you should know i don't care
what kind of family you come from what
status you are
there's the art to manage your money i
grew up you know there's no more of
these robber barons because they got 19
and they wiped all those guys out so
brother um
i'm just a strong believer and um
making deals and looking for deals yeah
that's why i went from here
an
entrepreneur i like the excitement of it
yeah yeah i like the risk of
calmness it tests you it tests your
humanity it's like sports
it isn't sport
remember was like 87. so doug williams
won and i was like that's my team yep
and i i've been loyal since
three guys started 91 is the last time
this company this thought start with a
thought in the dream in 2013
and now
you know this is a public trading
company
you know like without what i appreciate
about moneyline is the education because
i feel like a lot of us and i'm talking
about black white male female we don't
know
because the one percent is really what
controls
so i appreciate because the education
component from not only money line but
also
you know it's needed you know coming
from where we come from we're not taught
that just make mistakes because you
don't know what to do education comes
from more than just going to school but
that's what we do in life we don't we
get off the fence and we make mistakes
and we learn from our mistakes
in order to become a master you first
have to be a fool
you know nothing happens overnight
say that again be in order to become a
master you got to first move forward
yeah yes
food even wanted to accomplish that
hold on it's 33
[Music]
if you try to block it with one man
there's no chance look at aaron donnell
going against the right guard we know
that this is the weakest link on the
offensive line mike it's one on one look
what he's doing tomorrow two of them
literally no there's no two of them it's
one he got two guys the one guy grabbed
two guys no that's the problem mike how
you going every play put two people on
aaron donald that's like you bro
this dude from pittsburgh pennsylvania
penn hills the the poorest town they're
gonna do it the bangor's gonna do this
[ __ ] again
except 20.
mango's doing this [ __ ] again getting
him over hey who that who they who they
are
the game is over no let's go home mike
shut down the stream no shut down the
stream no don't shut it down stay right
here mike don't take this out of your
house please there you go
it's over my life is taking home fifty
to a hundred thousand dollars on all his
best this fight's far from over big
sensing
i did everything you told me to do right
now
i bet the way you told me to bet right
right respect he listened to me
he listened to me it's over
this is not over
hey remember fam we're giving another
25k away with moneyline coming up very
soon third quarter giving away 25.
fourth quarter giving away 25. that's
50k man 50k we gave away 50k last half
we're doing again this half right now
downloading these beautiful black people
uh app right now and you got a chance to
win 25k
beautiful black people amazing right
yeah
hey linda
have you had her on the show no i meant
this though before
i'll be here
yeah man god bless you y'all
[Music]
hey come here you don't have my number
you don't know
[Music]
you're a liar
wow oh ramadan
okay
[Music]
they're doing tattoos
they're tap people in the back there
right now okay well you can just freak
tattoos back
yeah are we still live right now we're
still live we're live right now anybody
that's here right now we're giving free
tattoos in the back this is crazy
they're not they're not watching the
stream in the house
yeah
we must have that second hand i don't
think they watch it
i speed
i wish i had those right i'm on this
carnivore diet right now
right yeah that's what you told me i'm
starting today let's start this
carnivore diet
if you ain't forming it don't eat it
you know it's in vegetables
yeah which will you tell me what's in
vegetables
there's some vegetables that are
poisonous that'll kill you
meat isn't a
basic consumption of meat alone is bad
every day in moderation meat
fish
um veg everything every day in
moderation what's your diet besides
uh psychedelics and weed what's your
might know what he's talking about it's
already dude right here bro
mike i didn't think i think it's not
realistic not to eat meat that's my
please i'm really like all right
all right let's go ladies and gents now
cause you got a lot of money on the line
well 14 to 20.
the los angeles rams are trailing by
seven
if you know how to count then you know
seven and the third are down by seven in
the third it's the third quarter okay
10 minutes left in the game
this is a crucial drive [ __ ]
bang bang you're putting a lot of
pressure on 25k you only got five kids
did you download more might you put more
on it i told him he said he's going to
pay for put five i want don't put down
twenty five thousand i'm fine mike you
don't need more than that you got way
too much money if you make twenty five
fifty a hundred thousand doesn't matter
you better put the five down be happy
watch what you're going
hold on dc
what is this 38 is right third longboard
we go for it
we go for it right that's the middle
three bout two it's not long enough to
do the draw or the screen this one we
actually break up convert
cooper cup
backyard
mike
that is classic back shoulder what
happens is that running back wide
receiver runs the go route
okay if the db is over top and i can't
get you to catch it over my shoulder
throw it back shoulder watch watch watch
this start marshall this is a pen plate
cooper cup is trying to get the pick
he's trying to get them safety to take
him
matthew stafford read it beautifully
through the back shoulder if he boss 55
and too [ __ ] slow how how how much
how do they have to change your game
plan now that odell beckham's out
because cooper's they can double cooper
cup remember odell came in what week 10
week 11 yeah falling though but he
played yeah but they already have the
chemistry and continuity
had to figure out how to implement it so
they're fine they're fine
thank god when did this
[Music]
allegedly boomer cyruson from the
cincinnati bengals ironically the
cincinnati bengals are in the super bowl
was the first team to implement the back
shoulder no no sorry phil sims in the
new york giants way back this back then
bro
seems like they were doing it that much
on the back shoulder
yes the commentators just weren't
noticing because bill parcells was the
head coach and bill parcells used to say
if my six three six four six five wide
receiver is open i mean if he's covered
he's open the store to him and that's
where the back shoulder was discovered
he's throwing the ball good too he got
so good at that
[Applause]
that's my sweat rack he's just gone
oh it was dropping
oh go
he was hurt he's been hurt yeah
oh they better watch out still no odell
[Music]
what does your wife and your kids call
you
[ __ ] oh so many i can't tell you the
name
so mr mike tyson
oh there's no odell beckham jr
this is devastating where is he at right
so
hopefully it's not an acl or mcl type
cert
and we'll see him recover quickly but
there's no jose beckham jr right now in
the biggest moment of his career you
just said they're gonna be fine
they'll be fine
but i'm thinking i'm speaking to the
players
we've played or fought
so we understand we're in a position we
know that
when you see most
broadcasts these guys covering the sport
they can't relate
so odell can you relate to odell in this
moment i think it's the biggest moment
of his career and he's not he's no more
worse he's the worst
because you understand the spot oh wow
it's always now your second and or third
you still have a chance to put any money
on this game
put everything on the cincinnati bengals
this guy
okay i play with these guys look at that
this game is all over
boom
think about what they did to the
cincinnati bengals last year patrick
last week patrick mahomes
the best quarterback in the business you
got smoking joe burrow on the sidelines
saying
he's calm now
he's caught up dc
he's calm he's no longer nervous
i mean
this guy get down
hey too much pressure too much pressure
too much pressure mike when you start
doing
reverse passes it's over too much
pressure yes that's gonna take
depression they're doing a double
reverse pass it's over they cannot take
the pressure my boy super comfortable
he's scrambling
the pressure look at the pressure
come on cooper cup play quarterback in
high school
you got to hit that cooper cup
his wife knows it see football players
know the moment this is a big moment we
needed that first down
it's kind of like how you was earlier i
didn't get 16. it was like how you was
earlier
earlier when i was fighting you and i
hit you with the hook and he was like ah
like okay this football player he might
have a little too much i swear
to god
illusion bro
mike what's up man you know you can't do
better than me
no i can't i
underneath me we're good
awesome 100 yeah introduce yourself man
yes my name is i'm a tick tocker a
couple drinks in right now and have a
fun a couple of fun questions
all right
in the [ __ ]
marsh you ain't got your dog broken
[ __ ] money got a dollar
margin
all right
who the hell
me
but i got a couple fun questions for you
all okay about the super bowl all right
it's a competition between you all okay
all right
the first question is
how many pounds of potato chips are
going to be eaten today
in the nation how many pounds of potato
chips are going to be 8000 [ __ ] no
i know i got points
millions 1 billion dc says a million
what about you 10 000. 10 000 pounds
how many times you got to convert it oh
ten thousand tons yeah that's times two
thousand oh see
you're a money lion
do they pay you for that what what is
that what is it what's the number
11.2 million pounds of potato chips
what's that divided by 2 000 i don't
know
call the money like guys
11 million divided by 2 000 what do we
got
all right that's not enough that's it
all right second question
how many chicken wings are eaten today
chicken wings what do you got how the
[ __ ] i know
i'm with tyson on this i'm sorry about
that [ __ ]
150 million
people's
viewing live the super bowl i'll say one
two three four the number one food yeah
each person averages five chicken wings
that's it
twenty are going to eat okay so this is
500 million let's do 51 million times
five fifty minutes absolutely
what is the number 250 250 that's the
number 1.4 billion chicken wings are
eaten today that's a lot of dead chicks
hey you're a business major this is what
i do at school i'm not a business major
i'm a football manager
i just do business
hey john's a great case study
all right at the final fantasy
[ __ ] right here how much money
is los angeles making today because of
the super bowl they're losing right now
i know let me tell you why they're like
no not the city not the city though
let me tell you what about fans oh cause
the new sla rams made the super bowl
their home team
so you got to think about travis knowing
that the airlines
the hotels
so
when
six weeks ago
everything was times five
when the rams won the nfc
north the nfc
okay conference
everything was cut in half by cut cut by
half i chose to make that because
everybody's here already yeah the people
are here you don't have to travel that's
right
i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm with my i love it
i love it 925 million 925 million
you're the closest 500 millionaires
this freaking guy is the businessman oh
yeah and you know what i am
i'm the freaking head of the freaking
army
all right like i'm gonna go get it let's
go
you're you just turned 21. uh three
months ago but i'm still trying drinks
you got a recommendation for me i don't
know too much oh whiskey just 18. can't
go wrong sweet whiskey no proper 12 how
dare you hey
tiger thick whiskey is he here don't
listen to him
that's his partner that's his partner i
own it
tiger thing is it a tequila no it's an
american whistle so everybody watching
right now tiger thing
go we're gonna find it what can we find
is japanese it'll be online i'll blast
out we have distribution all over the
nation so listen you know what's the one
thing you got to understand let me teach
you you're 21 right 21. when mike tyson
or b or dc drives their company
we need the support because mike tyson
is also employing
300 400 people
and those 300 400 people are making
their communities better so we thought
when we talk about generational wealth
we got to support i mean what does that
even look like right right only he would
not like what 100 million look like mike
yeah it doesn't fill this building up
it doesn't fill this room up no
no a couple briefcases
for mike with 100 100 buildings doesn't
fill this room really 100 million 100
million
wow
wow that's crazy he's going with that
touchdown mike the only one that doesn't
have 100 bills
that's my my give me a million right now
mike
what's holding you back from giving me a
million what i got to do to get a
million from mike tyson
like eating that fruit
i can't do
mike's a bullying um friend
shut the [ __ ] up
the bronzeville bully
brownsville bar
come on like one [ __ ]
how many followers
oh you can see him here right yeah
[Music]
when is this [ __ ] over
you all right thank you doctor bro
thank you bro that young man came in
here and got body slammed bobby marshall
and then forced to smoke weed
awesome bag y'all some bullies man
shut the [ __ ] up
why are you talking to them
you know
mike why are you talking like that bro
[Laughter]
i [ __ ] smoke this
just give me five yards staffer that's
it bam he gave me five yeah that's okay
so now it's starting manageable dc
that means we go for it
i mean i'm gonna go for it like i'm
talking about trying to get it we're not
giving the draw okay we're not doing
like i gotta explain yourself because
you said we still but we're not
why did you pick the cincinnati bengals
i'm sweating laughing at this guy they
had a history of coming back from behind
so i reached my money on somebody like
that why because i know they wanted real
bad to desire to win
they were down the last three weeks to
make it to the super bowl they overcame
all right we got three about less than
three minutes left don't forget we're
giving away 25k in this third quarter
we've already given away 50 000
25 third quarter 25k in the fourth
quarter that guy did what you gotta do
is download the moneyline app right now
man it's super easy that's how you win
25k like i did download the moneyline
app mike's gonna lose 5k like i did get
your money roar tag going follow us on
social and comment your money
war tag 25k get away 50k let's go like i
did hey for anybody for anybody
[Music]
tell us who you want to come sit next to
me
mike why the hell is your feet so big
oh damn we got this
[ __ ]
is
he's so tight bro you know you guys know
this as athletes mike is so tight he
look it's like attention i'm not gonna
start stretching
every day why you so tight huh why are
you so tight no need for me to be tired
why does he want my foot
i can't take this [ __ ] man my queer size
15 don't hit me mike don't hit me with a
hook dawg
yo
why are you wearing bigger size than me
for easterly
mike six four
[Laughter]
me
no frill though oh my god are you good
you're good mike i'm horrible oh you're
horrible you little
what you doing
are you like are you are you into four
play
are you
one yeah are you in the fourth place he
said are you getting it
that's what we talking about like you
got rear size 14 and you five two you
wanna see my dick
with my foot
when you smoke that tyson everybody take
that tight
[Music]
he might hit me with a hook you better
leave that man alone though
i'm sweating
bro y'all got to leave michael on dog
they want to scoot through the middle
they want to scoot down they want to
scream
look you keep messing with it man
mike is coming back we're good and then
it might come back again with the
[ __ ] i'm gonna knock mike's ass out
[Laughter]
i'm trying to do the [ __ ] show man
mike this is big it's third down it's
starting again hold this watch it's a
big moment champ
mike you got a lot of money on the line
y'all
the cincinnati bengals is up but at any
moment this game can flip you have von
miller this is the problem
what he's doing to this right tackle
that's called a t e
that's a t e stunt
the defensive end comes out
[Applause]
get the ball out quick oh that ain't
[ __ ] that's the player yeah
that's all he needed right there dude
you hear mike mike talking about like my
talking about that's all we needed right
there
why are you [ __ ]
hey
mike tyson toad
there we go
i wish mike ty go big big moment in the
game right here hey mike
whenever you do that frog stuff how long
does it last huh how long does it like
last the psychedelic 20 minutes
[Applause]
but you're going to feel like a 2 000
hour
you're going to feel like 2 000 years
hey mike
mike is it a drop or you're licking the
frog no you're drunk smoking oh smoke
but like it only lasts 40 minutes
i'm going to take you right to god
really but it makes you kind of like go
like different
it helps you rise to your highest
potential
yeah look at mike d.c you try it i was a
junkie i was on the joke i was on
cocaine i was like oh dinos i almost
died i just told
look at me
this is my party
huh everything changed
y'all guys know you guys read about me i
mean i was [ __ ] up i was dying now i
don't even i can't even believe this
[ __ ]
[ __ ] paid me to have a party
[Music]
that's crazy
yeah cincinnati's winning though
they're about to be losing though i i
bet you ran score this big drive right
here it's also only four years
they got the game a lot of people coming
a lot of people coming into this game
we're giving away 25k kids let's go
download the app moneyline
and you know what we just gave away 25k
so you missed out
don't be sad just giving away 25k in the
fourth quarter tiffany duke just won 25
with money line hey people really
looking at this [ __ ]
right
unless you're overly rich you should be
downloading this app people really look
good you should be trying to win extra
money
there mike what's up mike saying we're
really watching this [ __ ] yes right now
we got thousands of people watching
right now
yes
of course you're mike tyson this is
awesome [ __ ] that's what he sees
four quarters mike smoking another blunt
everybody mike it's the fourth quarter
hey this is the championship rounds
right now are we live right now i'm like
yeah we're live
with that kid was over here hey
everybody watching right now
this is the championship round
the fourth quarter you're gonna see 53
guys on the sideline holding up the
floor and what that means and what that
symbolizes is that
this
is where champions
are made
okay
where's my character right there he came
back mike it's my channel
i appreciate it can i
tell our house
can i be the exclusive sponsor of code
here
my name okay
you gotta do business with mike mike
real now
what you're looking for how much you
looking for
that
is
oh bro
this young man bro you ain't rushing for
a fraternity
you're high enough so i'm pretty high
well inhale yeah be responsible
starts lighting up hey that's good
that's something
strong mike's bro it really is
hey young man have you smoked weed
before yeah okay
i hope this is not true you smoke weed
every day
no okay it's good we're gonna be higher
what the [ __ ] is this liquor i i drink
tequila you smoke weed
how much you can get i deal with that
you good with that yeah you got to
educate me though and i'm not [ __ ]
because no no no mike i do believe from
an anxiety depression standpoint
and stress management
psychedelics and marijuana i can learn
from it and i can embrace it differently
for real so like that's real and that's
why i love listening to you
in hot boxing because you're educating
people
i'm just getting high [ __ ]
my mother win that money though
mike what are you going to do with the
money when you when the cincinnati [ __ ]
excuse me
what are you doing with the earnings
from your
your your bet it's 5 000.
what are you doing with that money i'm
going to disneyland [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i love you i'll get out of here
yeah get out for it might get you down
that pool you stay on the straight
narrow young man no more drugs hey man
stay away from people like this group
yeah you're going to be young
you'll be good
here we go
third and seven
empty formation they went for it all
they went that's a big box phase
that's that's that's jefferson his
father
was a legend at the university of
central florida and then also with the
detroit lions he's a wide receiver coach
right now in the nfl oh wow let's do
this next level but it's in the
bloodline [ __ ] in the deadline 100
but if that's odell beckham jr he comes
down with this now we're missing odell
beckham the reality is eli apple is
terrible
uh
eli apple's getting off okay you know
who he is though
how are you playing with the saints you
know he like halfway really [ __ ]
you know football
but you know eli airplane regarding [ __ ]
i might say facts and i'm gonna move on
[Laughter]
double dog hey that's dc one of the
greatest fighters of all time we're
talking about ufc double
double champs this dude knows football
he's talking about eli apple and why
this guy was able to go from the saints
and not a cincinnati bengals and still
give up planes
he's still giving up places
second down oh my god mike what's going
to happen what's the outcome man we got
13 minutes left
we have a lot of time we got a lot of
time talk to the people what's happening
what's going on what's going to be the
album hey listen right now
they're fighting with one another not
really any technique just becoming
successful
we're going to hope um
in the
next down will get better i think he's
34.99
again
[Laughter]
remember hold up fellas it's the fourth
quarter we've got another 25 000 to give
out 25k
is going out download the monday live
get your money raw tag going follow us
on social comment using the money
uh roar tag do all that download the
video oh my man it's your last chance to
win 25k we've given out 75 000 during
this entire freaking
streaming whatever you want to call it
look we're gonna we are in a minute
obj's in the street clothes oh man
it's bad
he looked like he was tearing up
oh he's a huge asset to the team yeah he
is
it's just odd seeing the bengals in the
super bowl
i mean
was the last time they played the super
bowl
the band played the 49ers was like icky
woods
that's bad and he had his dance remember
the icky man you know what he danced him
and his mother had a commercial
you remember the icky do the icky
shuffle [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm not a good leader okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's on the all my sister oh oh that's a
good sign he's walking up come on yes
you know
is he yeah we good yeah you can walk we
good nah [ __ ] if you could breathe you
good
you could breathe oh hell yeah it's on
the bengals but here's the thing
that deepens the line it's something
i'm gonna say roughness
here's the deal people look at this this
is barn miller
necessary
a new mvp
that's not unnecessary roughness that's
just football mike no he hurt him too
bad no not necessary oh my goodness mike
you can't even fight you can't play
football in these times
not that bad the guy pushed me mike is
right it's a 16 billion dollar industry
don't hurt the quarterback joe borrows
the face
mike is right
they can say well they better hold these
guys man
whoa
here we go
all right man you know what i like that
b i don't like seeing odell on the
sideline no it's not gone
man
uh but he came back
yeah
so here here's the deal folks right now
i'm with joe burrows feeling
you think my career is over or this game
is over and then once the pain subsides
and you're like oh i can still do it
that's [ __ ] we'll know in the next
10 minutes if joe burrow can finish this
game you better put up with that facial
expression so that initial reaction
it's like that pain is so tough you know
that
and then you're like [ __ ] you think as
an athlete my career is over the game is
over that adrenaline got to carry that
driller yeah you know
it's got to carry them it's a super bowl
you got to try to finish it you have to
and i guarantee you joe burrow's a
gangster guarantee doesn't sit
all out
it's like what happened to me and you
were fighting
yo
yo put me in the choke hold your ass
will be asleep
you think so i would do it you remember
hey how many how long do you think i'll
last
[Applause]
i would say 35 seconds rachel i would
shoot you something you'd rush in
i would grab i would shoot at your legs
yeah 35 seconds but you're not going to
catch my legs
oh so that's what i said it doesn't
matter how long you're going to run so
okay you should have my legs you're
getting my legs in what's going
[Music]
[Laughter]
bro you feel like oh my goodness take
that seven seconds and you just go to
sleep
that's it you go to sleep bro you just
did that and i said oh my goodness
he goes in your neck
like i felt my damn what is this called
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like this yeah it's all technically
so what's that what's what's my play if
i if a guy get me there you gotta fight
that hand fight you gotta fight two on
one chin now
chin down fight the top hand
is this one they can't let my hands you
can't let my hands lock baseball bat two
on one yeah two you want to go there
with one arm who's the best uh
at grappling and who's the best i've
been out of it i beat him i'm not
retired though but he's retired
right now
islam
he's just like habib oh charles oliveira
charles oliveira bronx there you go if
charles lavera gets your neck it's over
look look that's why you always see
muscle remember you put that guy i got a
small little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he just hey dc just putting a chokehold
on me and it might be like two seconds
he asked me like he said put the choke
on i gave him a little taste mike he
went like that
he's a [ __ ] master kiss [ __ ]
the joke yeah the man he likes he likes
pain
i do you like me yeah he enjoyed
whatever
you you want to get in the ring you
wanna go 12 rounds i'm going 12 rounds
hey you know what if you want to go to
ufc in three freaking [ __ ] ass rounds
the first 30 seconds of those [ __ ] ass
rounds didn't pass out
against dc
no no i'll give you my turn
two rounds out last with dc two rounds
two rounds ten minutes
dc here's the thing you might drop it
i'm not afraid of you putting me out so
i might knock you out
because oh man i like your choice
[Laughter]
that's like me trying to guard you in
the football field no it's not it is
it's a fight
it's like me trying to guard you the
football field mike tell him it's a
fight
i can't i can't believe that we're doing
this on television
i just can't me neither you might think
about this mike i can't go on a football
field and chase him to not stop and make
a touchdown he's going to make a
touchdown
man-to-man coverage i can't stop you
you're going to destroy it but you're
telling me that you can go inside of an
eight-sided octagon and go 10 minutes a
week no
but the best some of the best fighters
in the world haven't been able to go 10
minutes that's right but you're going to
do better than them yes
you're crazy
because it comes down to mindset listen
you know what you all know who you
knew i
i are i can't guard you on that football
field bro no but in fighting
yeah and fighting yet no not about
taking a punt it's about
you say this about that no no it's not
everybody
everybody's a champion until they get
punched in their mouth let's see that's
it be marching
out when you get in that ring any kind
of fight when you're getting that ring
you think you're a tough guy and you try
to get in that ring you better be helped
you gotta be careful you don't fought
that of a heart attack [ __ ] they get
tired now like what do you mean they get
tired now as soon as you come in the
ring the presence in that ring is it's
like
mike hey the way you're hey when you're
out there it's like walking in that way
and getting in there is everybody
watching
everybody watching you i like playing in
front of seventy thousand dollars
four million lives but it's not all
right you'll be marching
up how many more three players when we
go out every march we're in there with
no clothes are we in our underwear fight
barefoot you as bear you as you are as
better today
make the fight no shirt make the fight
enough talking marshall talking beat
marshwatch
make the fight make the fight make it
happen now
make the fight
he retired for two years i'm retired for
two and a half it's it's easy he's gonna
stop saying please i'm sorry and all
that [ __ ]
mike
what you need how many meals you need
tell mike what you need right now you're
gonna start you're gonna start
apologizing everything mike oh hell yeah
no no no you don't be like god
promoter he's gonna say can you teach me
that tell him
to do it i don't know what you want you
know why i don't want to do it why i
need to do it
then i feel the obligation then to go
and try to guard you on the football
field and i'm not going to be
embarrassed
it's not that exactly
but you fighting me is not fair in the
octagon it is
[Music]
i don't understand this
dc
camera look at his face he's actually
serious
what is that
shake shack oh i can't see that
what is it i thought i thought you're
saying more whiskey on ice
you want whiskey that's what this guy
wants yeah i can't hey
you know what i would love to do though
for real
i'd like to match you up with somebody
else no no no no i just wanted to come
just mess around logan paul like you
know what i'm saying come here
respectable come to the gym and we just
i have to absolutely go to the academy
i love i love wrestling yeah but i've
seen i could tell that you've done a
little bit of boxing yes your job you
can tell right away from the moment you
have yeah you're moving tonight you've
hit me you know who i want i went to
[Applause]
would be down i just i did a show with
him probably a month ago he's in shape
too of course too yes thanks brother
co's down that would be a good one we
can watch that
hey tio in shape
yeah bro
i did a podcast with them
i can't eat those thank you i need you
might be drunk
championship rounds damn
first
[Music]
they picked up seven yards now you guys
second
we're talking about time and possession
control the clock
control the clock yeah we're in the
fourth quarter
that defensive line is built to rush
run the ball let's go come on yeah come
on
yes
[Music]
that's right it's still manageable
hey bee marsh really wants to fight
trillo somebody get [ __ ] up on my
tysons
hey mike come to tv mike
mike mike come grab them
mike don't want to deal with brandon
i can't do this
mike's i can't believe they're paying
this [ __ ] ding ding yeah
the people who want mike tyson back
you better hope mike don't learn to kick
but that's nice
y'all got to stop doing that on this one
[Music]
once he gets mad it's over i got him now
he's slow you don't want to any problems
no bro
you don't want those mike guys involved
in the doubles
one of the greatest heavyweights of all
time and ufc
doesn't matter yeah like 14 mike tyson
doesn't matter it's just like this joe
nixon
is wiling out on joe mixon let's go baby
underdogs we've been to underdogs our
entire life let's go
second down yeah a lot of the fourth
quarter seven minutes to go it's 16 to
20. what are we going to do you got
matthew stafford sitting on the
sidelines saying oh my goodness i've
been in detroit for twice
what happened
here we go
you better chill man all right
there ain't enough tequila in the world
it would be marshmallow ain't got enough
to keep marshall i don't like this push
hey leave iron mic alone
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
dc we got 19 keys here
it's another one we talk about money
live we talk about we're here to roar
what's up brother
the change dome dog you're changing we
got 19 keys one of the guys in this
space right now that's educating our
guys bro
we talk about these dudes right here
making
a crap ton of money how would you advise
them to watch the game though
you know when we look at statistics when
we look at nfl players we look at
athletes we see a lot of them lose their
money
[Applause]
learning how to keep your money and
advance your money to the next
generation is the key
so whether you got to put in
diversification man you gotta put your
money in nfts put it somewheres go make
you some money in the long term you
understand me that's the game that we
post to play you got to have a trust set
up got to have an estate setup just
interesting
right because it's interesting when you
think about money lying they do nfts
crypto yeah every platform where you
want to bank with them you can do so
many other things so it's interesting
that you say that
nfts talk to me about nfts talk to me
about crypto well it's really just a way
where we can get to on our own you
understand me where you look at
historically systems of control and
manage your money now you get to manage
it for you when you get to manage your
career where if i'm an nfl player i'm
gonna go ahead and take my image and my
likeness and find a way to capitalize on
it outside of my contract and there's a
lot of creative ways that a person can
do that outside the business you
understand me but that goes really for
any and everybody it's one thing to buy
into cryptocurrency nfts allow you to
earn cryptocurrency
in the future
say that again it's one thing to buy
into cryptocurrency you understand me
but it's another thing to be able to
earn cryptocurrency and if crypto will
be the money in the future then we got
to be tapped into the digital revolution
the dollar is consistently going down
inflation is very high so we got to make
sure that we not only have financial
literacy but financial liberation
sit with us
so we're here super bowl 56 you got the
los angeles rams the home team for real
playing against the cincinnati bengals
the game is legendary we got a couple
minutes left six minutes seven minutes
left in this game it's going to go down
as one of the greatest games ever i'm
telling you right now i don't know if
odell beckham jr is going to go back in
the locker room and put on the suit i
don't know that but what i do know is
the chair the heavyweight champion of
the world
okay has a lot of money on the line yeah
i have 19 keys here that's educating us
while we're watching the super bowl
love you
stay right here
that's b that's dc
dc
you know you know 19 keys you would just
introduce them to us
hey we're gonna i gotta go to the
bathroom we're gonna take you guys
on a big level i know man what do you do
with
uh i don't moneyline
anything with them man i'm a thought
leader so i usually teach those who
teach everybody else
i got my own platform
you know we speak truth to power and at
the same time i teach people well master
mindset but also how to utilize this
technology
you know it's it's great to see like
young people
actually you know what it's true young
people like starting to
be more involved in terms of leadership
it's all about knowledge too that's why
this isn't a push of money line but i
think about money line is they have
original content educating people like
oh you want to buy your first car or
yeah you're buying your first home or
you want to you know your personal
trainer that's how you make the money
just have to hustle just yeah but how
old are you 31.
so when we were kids there was they
don't teach you that in school they
wouldn't know what kind of financial
taxes like how to make money i mean i
didn't have any of those things as well
that's why i just had to do
self-education yeah
self-education is a new harvard you
understand me yes sir because we all
went to school and got the wrong
education then we had to relearn and
unlearn everything they taught us in
order to do the right thing and then the
outliers figured it out but now those
outliers can educate the young yeah
well you know like wealth is a buzzword
but at the end of the day
if we all teach wealth i teach family
first you understand because meaning
ain't no wealth unless you can pass it
down yes sir you understand me and
social well i don't do business without
family you understand me those are the
dynamics that we set up and then we
teach people skill sets to buy assets
you understand me i'm not telling you to
just go get a job i'm gonna teach you a
money skill so you can do for self at
the end of the day i just look at the
leadership that we've had historically
throughout the past and i try to figure
out if i can stand on the shoulders that
we can go further and if i got that
blueprint why wouldn't i be able to yeah
and we got phones and technology so we
ain't got no excuses no the information
is it's on you to figure it out it's
available i mean y'all fighters so i
look at the league
of that and i always look at every place
and i say okay how could you advance
that and how can you take everybody
complaints and instead turn into a
business model right so it's like
attention is what allows platforms to be
able to convert that
but now you got the ability to create
your own platforms and monetize them you
got the business acumen you got the
skill
but when you can merge those two
together then you got everything you
need everything you need
really you can do it all from your phone
you really can't should i just get it
all for my phone there's there's no
excuses none
a lot of people put excuses in front of
the opportunities yeah those nice
necklaces too huh yeah you know i'm just
investing man
i got one
i got one i need a [ __ ] my shirt
that's weak right now melanie wear it
all the time i just this this uh
my my spiritual mentor so i'm gonna keep
that on my neck at all times because you
talk the economic blueprints of black
people in america so i'll keep that and
then i always wear my crown and
represent knowledge itself
so everywhere i go i gotta be a
reflection of what i stand for my man
well said bro
fourth and one
now we don't got this weird [ __ ]
here right yeah
i'll be march yeah people just wanna
take a [ __ ] he went to the bathroom yeah
champ he went to the bathroom champ well
you've been in a hot second though
champ don't a champ we got four minutes
left don't get in before we get on there
don't get him on here
i've been to that
i got tired of getting
those those lawsuits broke me down yeah
they broke me down i bet they were fun
though
they broke me down
champ how you got the shape like that
how you got in shape like that you were
heavy for a while
you got in shape like real shape
i did um not running
blood spinning you still run jam
yeah i did blood spinning
okay how'd that work
the blood spinning they take your blood
out
you are fitting it all up
they're booming
put it back in and that's the night
build up the energy in the blood i'm i'm
what they call it again it's called prp
prp but another word
they call it another
plasma replacement yes
stem cells
you spar still or you just kind of hit
fast no i just hit the back but
periodically
you can't run every day like you used to
because you start breaking you down
you're hitting back everything
so now you got to take two days off and
come back
all right we're playing now right come
on mike you're nervous about your money
that's right you nervous about your
money
no you're good
hey mike whenever you fight no young
y'all run a mile for every every round
a mile per round
no um
12 hours nobody got paid more to spar
with me no i'm saying like when you were
running on your road work yeah did you
want one mile for every round for like
12 miles no i did i ran 20 miles before
20 miles yeah i did a 20-mile run before
that's that road work
that's a real road work go cool come on
get this guy that's receiving the nfl
mango keep on the bags
look at all these people rooting for
these people man
so right now we're getting into
situational things l.a locals gonna
stick together you feel me situationally
i got to focus on the situation at hand
oh no
boom we throw it down mr relax our
second down and manageable okay
we're in the red zone there's so much
going on right now they're trying to
score this guy trying to score
of course
mike what do you want right here do you
want to last or do you want to run
i don't know they putting pressure on
the bango you gotta it's only two that's
it you can pass where you can run that's
it
what do you wanna pass it
past it all right
it looks like it we got three by one got
one run back in the backfield they
choose a run so they they didn't
yes sir how much money is being spent
or what's going on right now in the city
of los angeles because the super bowl is
millions
it is in the billions right millions
like you wouldn't believe it
they just said
it might be tens of billion we gotta we
gotta we got a spending problem
everybody in the mayor got a spending
problem well it's inflation right now
though i know but we need to have an
investment problem you understand me
that's the solution is like they put out
there that black people got 1.6 trillion
spending power but we lost 14 of our net
worth it's because it's spending meaning
it's going out if you circulate it
you're coming back to poor origin if you
invest in this giving you a return on
your money
invest in real estate probably the
safest place not just real estate right
now real estate probably gonna have a
bubble for everything that's going on
it's very high you understand me uh but
you got crypto you got gold you got nfts
you got blockchain technology you
understand you got stocks right
historically stocks and businesses go
get you the best returns but now you got
crypto if you know how to invest it in
the right way and then after all this
regulation happen it should be good at
least when you're looking at the top
sector
we have to look at the reality too
everybody's not going to get rich
everybody percentage is not high in that
perspective but that's why it's like if
the average person just invests 500 or a
thousand in bitcoin if it continues to
go up this way you'll be all right
there's not enough bitcoin for every
millionaire to own one
you understand me so you don't have to
have a lot before a standard of living
in the future you gotta hunt something
it's about education listen if you have
500.
i don't know anything about this but i
have it
i know see that's the key there you go
i don't have smart people around you who
help you
i don't know if it's going to be worth
anything if i prepare for the future
even though i don't know what it is well
sure the only key against the risk right
now is diversity so you got to invest in
everything that's the only way it's
going to work out that's what your money
matters is that's not the rich that is
the wealthy richest frame of mind you
can have a billion dollars and be poor
yeah
you know yeah i mean you know i look at
welfare's the abundance mindset
if you balance you can go in the
negative you can go into positive but if
i'm abundant i got enough to give away i
know but wealth is the value that you
have in yourself i'm not wealthy you
know i mean because i'm valuable i'm
valuable because i'm wealthy well see
that's in the mental aspect but in the
power aspect numbers your ability to be
able to move power and energy
collectively like this people that's
rich and you know in order to guide you
the rich didn't get there by saying they
were from the mental perspective
absolutely mentalism is key i develop
it's the precepts every everything in my
mind that's what my womb is that's why i
give birth but then i'm gonna work it
into existence that's my formula
so i teach people to mindset eighty
percent mindset twenty percent skill set
but if you ain't got the mindset you
ain't gonna never develop the skill set
to execute you
listen
i don't have the mindset well back then
when i was the young i don't have the
mindset right but you got a belief yes
and i have and i have the money no uh i
don't have to educate you i have nothing
to have money your sister uh jackie
told me some great stories about you
when you were younger so you always had
a vigor
to believe in yourself or energy when
you gonna go forward regardless
people don't go and then you converted
that different i want to be up more than
anybody wants me to be down yeah
and there's a lot of people that want
you down in here here we go b-mark it's
not gonna happen oh it's wide open
listen this is gonna be the bingos okay
we're in the red zone
everything's about numbers the numbers
game right now is not favoring
but los angeles well you got four plays
right now the rounds about to score
they're gonna go up twenty three this is
the rapture is gonna start cheating for
them this is what you gotta do to see
what josh mcdaniels of the new elite
patriots
that's pressure man too much pressure
yeah man bro it's not the first read
that quarterback got to get outside the
pocket and receivers got to keep running
to actually score a touchdown
keep moving watch this boom
that's the pressure
pressure
why why not five yards well what you got
to understand is these db's don't have
to backpedal nut right now
they can sit there at the goal line
people remember the back in line is
their friend another defender how many
throws do they have left
they got two they got third down they
got fourth down mike tyson
okay is asking brandon i like watching
mikey because
watch this running back picking up 10.
watch this running back
no
oh
that's [ __ ] right that's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ]
that was all yeah they're gonna get him
on the left mike i think they don't get
him on the left one
right away
this guy don't even look right
he doesn't even look right this guy
ain't down for our pizza
that dude look like larry hello
wilson's been playing a phenomenal game
let's see if it's but look look look
look look oh you can't do that we can't
all right look at this
hold on timeout is it within five yards
nope if it's with this stop it's not
it's not all right then it's a penalty
mike that was a little referee man
oh he's talking [ __ ] he got lit up he
got lit up can't
[Music]
because 70 of the time mike when you
blitz matthew stafford touch he converts
seven is your target number that's real
those that's that's learned that's
understanding the game percent of the
time teams who blitz matthew staff
that's the best option
man cooper cup eastern washington yeah
but he got him in the face well michael
kiyosa loves hang on watching me dude
[ __ ]
oh
[Laughter]
mike talk to us about now talk to us
about branding and marketing
branding and marketing
yeah
you are your brand is who you are
my brand is not me i'm the brand
so i have to represent my brand new web
and in order to accomplish what i want
to accomplish to be the best in the
world of what i do
i got a question for you i always kind
of wondered about this you remember that
thing you used to wear was like that cut
towel yeah was that your idea was that
something you guys thought of like the
guys in the 20s and 1915 used to wear it
oh really they didn't have roads back
then i always wondered why you wore that
it was [ __ ] cool
and short shorts that's a great question
why said short shorts
check the bill
oh the left left the less clothes you
have on the more people come yeah dude
that tall thing i was like explaining
because i remember that
explain that less clothes we have on the
[ __ ] bill
i know but explain what i mean
we're over sexualized
everything sex we look at yeah that's
the fact that everything everything you
look at well i don't like the [ __ ] that
wow
wow i hit that with nobody knows you
know
your whole life is sexualized
mike know hey just look at the halftime
look at the halftime show mary j blige
look yeah look at the people dressed in
here
hey mike when you order one when you
wore the towel and tupac walk you to the
ring that's the most iconic ring one of
all times
when he was coming out with tupac
walking to the ring in vegas most iconic
ring walkers of all time still what made
you say i walk by eat your babies
because i wanted to
i've never
no neighborhood more dangerous than up
here
[Music]
who was your favorite arena mgm or
mandolin
madison square and madison mgm right got
so much history now yeah every time i
fought there you could feel the history
like every time and then in the hallways
they got all you guys pictures in there
like from the big events yeah when
you're walking through the hallways to
fight you'd see a picture of you
yeah here we go
[Applause]
that back
that back shoulder is like an uppercut
yeah i'm here all night yeah and then
all of a sudden boom it get me it's
sneaky it's sneaky yeah it's sneaky
look who guardian
happened on the numbers
he's the best
scored 20 22 it's about the best in the
world though why would they leave cooper
cup like that one i'm out
no 10 35 left
there's a minute and 25 seconds yeah
you got smoking joe burrow
still wow
touchdown not even a field team
money line give me a thousand a thousand
dollars
right now right now smoking joe you got
it thousand and one my thousand a year
two thousand
what are we doing
this boy won odds
[Music]
yeah oh 100 percent right now he's going
to be joe's on the other side saying
it's overnight so fast
though not so fast that's the war going
on looking look at staff yes oh my
goodness i'm out of detroit yeah world
champion can you believe that and you
got your mark chase
first you got smoking joe burrow over
there
smoking joe is locking one up right now
yeah
that's your bill
we're giving another 25 koa that's a
hundred thousand dollars we told you
moneyline ain't playing man
how do they how do they win the money
how they win the money down the money
line
right there it's the last one this is it
it's too late now there's a minute 25
left in game aaron johnson you won 25
be smart with your investments talk my
man right here yeah man 25k increase
your chances of winning
[Applause]
shout out to moneyline thank you guys
okay
man mike what's the name in this dance
i have no idea bro what is it is that
greedy
that's what they do in cincy no
louisiana lsu boys yeah louisiana
don't take that from us b
that's on jalen too that's just crazy
right now it's a good game anything can
happen right now man blue 32 hood hut
i'm throwing up side to the left stack
yeah i like seeing that
[Music]
i'll go straight up 1000 a business out
you got a thousand i got it down all
right
you better catch it come on come on
oh [ __ ] you can't tell your wife
you come over here
third and one mike third and one big
play
you the money man 19 keys money lying
yeah you know
what's the odds what's the odds well
i'ma tell you man the best thing you can
do right now when the game is like this
is take your money and invest it in
crypto instead
much better odds i promise i'm trying to
get a thousand from b morrison that's
freaking crazy that gave what made a
terrible bet smoking germany the
terrible 1000
[Music]
right now
i don't know why they running around
i like a good fight though no opposite
if
if our fighters
if our fighters know that then why
doesn't our office love love hey right
here like the coach the coach now
young head coach taylor fans
he's nervous for fans
yes it's the best it's still possible
[Music]
oh
look at him mike look at that
one look at him go to work mike oh my
goodness
shake him up
mvp what are the 99 99
what are we doing 99 70 feet oh better
number than that is
tell the ceo of moneyline to kids ass
over here
why don't we get a thousand dollars i
just lost that what can happen they
can't do nothing now no they can't do
this
that's his bet that's all that's
marshall's bet
tell the ceo not to pay it for him mike
i'm sorry mike lost 25.
it's okay
it's okay mike saddle what eight eight
nine that's mike don't like to lose a
lot of people
they they they they get in over the head
yeah
five
it's cool for him yeah some people like
doing too much well i don't think you
should never spend more at any given
time wanting five or ten percent of your
money especially if it's not an
investment
damn wow what a game though the boy
woodwork got a title 40 years old
he's 40 years old bro yeah
that was a fun game though it was a good
game
mike how you feeling out there man you
sad about the 5k or not sure
i like to lose yeah
you just don't like to lose my champ
come on
not even a little bit
[Applause]
that's a big win
cooper cup mvp right
super tough mvp right now
bro he had seven or sevens two times a
thousand back
[Laughter]
i guess it's over
the show is over now right the show's
over moneyline thank you guys all the
winners congrats over a hundred thousand
dollars
listen you still download the moneyline
app they have great content on there you
guys it's a smart thing to do shout out
to moneyline shout out to mike tyson
dc
b mars thanks hold it down
love it i love you all
we're out we love you guys
go rams super top mvp
that was love man
[Music]
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
system
so
[Music]
do
you